[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es eine leckere Schmorpfanne
aus dem Ofen und zwar habe ich hier eine
rindfleischschmorpfanne mit Pasta sehr
sehr lecker mit überschaubaren Zutaten
und das Ganze ist etwa in 10 Minuten
zubereitet kommt dann für zwei Stunden
in den Ofen und dann ist es so zart dass
ihr Denken könntet es war die ganze
Nacht im Backofen weil es einfach so
zart verschmilzt ich zeige euch mal die
Zutaten für den Schmortopf ich nehme
etwas Olivenöl eine Zwiebel zwei
Knoblauchzehen vier rote Spitzpaprika
die habe ich Rindfleisch das sind 600
Gramm Roastbeef dann noch Gewürze Salz
und Pfeffer natürlich ein paar
Lorbeerblätter das sind jetzt drei
kleine einen Esslöffel Senfkörner die
habe ich etwas Essig zwei Esslöffel und
500 g Rinderbrühe ihr könnt schon mal
ein bisschen Olivenöl in der Pfanne
erhitzen ich nehme jetzt hier die Samira
Gusseisenpfanne denn das Gericht wird
erstmal angebraten und später dann im
Ofen weiter geschmort damit es schön
zart ist
also hier schon mal erhitzen
dann werde ich die Zwiebel und
Knoblauchzehen schälen und fein
schneiden
ich schneide das jetzt hier einfach in
Scheiben
und beim Fleisch habe ich schon so
gemacht ich habe es schon vor einer
Weile aus dem Kühlschrank geholt damit
es nicht mehr so kalt ist damit es schön
zart wird und nicht eiskalt in die
Pfanne kommt weil dann zieht sich gern
zusammen durch den kälter Hitzeschock
deswegen am besten immer ein bisschen
akklimatisieren lassen
[Musik]
dann die Paprika schön mit einem braten
und jetzt kann ich das Roastbeef hier in
Stücke schneiden am besten mal schauen
ob was einiges dran ist das wird dann
entfernt und dann eigentlich wieso
Geschnetzeltes zubereiten
gegen die Faser schneiden
zeige ich euch mal hier wenn man nämlich
sieht das Fleisch geht in die Richtung
schneidet man quer dazu
wunderbar sieht es hier aus
schaut mal den Dunstabzug bis gleich
höher
muss dazu sagen der stellt sich immer
automatisch ein das ist Abzug aber dass
er nicht immer auch volle Pulle arbeitet
wenn ich anbrate und ich beim
Motorrädern keine Störung habe schalte
ich den meisten runter ansonsten regelt
der das wirklich von alleine
es kommt hier das Fleisch dazu
jetzt habt ihr die Meisterarbeit schon
getan die Gewürze rein Essig Gemüsebrühe
Fleischbrühe war keine Gemüse alles mit
rein Deckel drauf und ab in den Backofen
für zwei Stunden ungefähr bei 160 Grad
und danach ist es total und so weich und
ihr könnt euch überlegen macht ihr
Nudeln dazu gibt Kartoffeln dazu
Reis ganz egal was ihr wolltet dann
gleich noch spontan aber momentan ist
mir nach Nudeln
[Musik]
das Schmorgericht ist fertig
und ich habe mich dazu entschlossen
Tagliatelle zu machen hier schon mal
abgegossen ich probiere jetzt einmal
kurz hier
denn Murat ist leider noch nicht da zum
Probieren und ich lass das jetzt hier
extra soßig wenn ihr das aber noch
eingedeckt haben wollt könnt ihr auch
noch stärker dazugeben
aber ich will dass die Nudeln
jetzt einfach mal hier
da muss man fast nicht kauen
so zart und so weich
wow aber ihr könnt euch wahrscheinlich
denken
ein bisschen Salz
ich habe erst gedacht mach noch Gewürze
und so dazu aber
es schmeckt wundervoll und jetzt mache
ich nämlich so so werde ich dann später
gleich servieren wenn wir essen
ich drehe jetzt hier einfach ein paar
Nestchen Trese da rein die Nudeln saugen
sich voll
[Musik]
dann ist das jetzt hier mein leckerer
Schmortopf ich wünsche euch ganz viel
Spaß beim Nachkochen falls ihr mehr
solche einfachen Rezepte sehen wollt
dann schreibt es mir gerne in die
Kommentare ich glaube Murat freut sich
jetzt riesig auf dieses essen die Kinder
auch wenn sie lieben auch passt damit
Fleisch und ich finde das ist ein
Gericht was man immer mal schnell
zubereiten kann dann im Ofen schmoren
lässt
es ist einfach immer lecker
Schmorgerichte liebe ich also das Rezept
findet ihr auf sallys-blog.de schaut da
gerne mal vorbei bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
[Musik]